[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations are in order for Jenna
Dewan enter fiance Steve Kazee who just
welcomed their first child together
the couple announced the happy news on
Instagram Tuesday morning posting
different pictures at the same time
Jenna shared this sweet black and white
snap of her holding her newborn with the
caption and just like that our hearts
exploded into all of eternity and beyond
welcome to the world you little angel
and Steve posted a photo of their son's
tiny hand in an instant our universe
burst wide open and nothing would ever
be the same
welcome to earth Starchild according to
both posts Jenna gave birth to son
Callum Michael rebel kizhi on Friday
it's mind blowing the whole thing
watching a child grow inside of a human
has been like the most amazing
experience so far we've opened up about
Jenna's pregnancy tewi teeth shortly
after the pair announced they were
expecting last September I felt a little
bit more tired and nauseous but overall
it's been great
and in December Jenna who was already
mother to six year old Everly whom she
shares with ex-husband Channing Tatum
shared with ET how our little girl is
feeling about becoming a big sister
she's really excited she's really
protective it's been cute she's worried
about what I'm eating making sure it's
healthy she when I say mommy needs to
sit down and take a break she's like
totally gets it she hugs and cuddles the
belly I mean it's really been adorable
you never know how it's gonna go and so
far she's been so excited she tells the
entire world everyone every way you can
just people that check us out at stores
she's like did she know my mom's right
there like we can see
[Music]